わーは折れちゃった婚とは品の保存分
4愛着やアメリカから帰ってからいらっしゃったしはず
ちゃんという入って言いアメリカから帰ってまいりましたはじめしゃちょーレッスン
受けて先週1週間ほど僕はアメリカに行ってたんですけども何をしに行ったかという話
でございましいった理由としてはまず映像関係の勉強っていうのはほぼ間違いではあり
ません毎年アメリカのカリフォルニア州で行われているヴィドコンというイベントに
参加してきました2010年から行っていてことしで7か
女らしいですもう youtube ファンとがクリエイターとかの人がで何万人も
集まって行う巨大なイベントでございますて
パソ34のイベントとかねこう面白いイベントとかもあるなかでもう傍らでフリーター
4の勉強会みたいなねマジな勉強会みたいな感じで宝木みたいにお話をちゃんと聞い
たりしていろいろわかったことがあって勉強になったこともたくさんありました
基礎的な部分も学べたんですけどまぁそれ以上に高 youtube に関してねくっ
そうだったのでなんかんわーみたいなちょっと驚くような内容もあったらねまぁ今後
そういうことでどんどんを生かしていければいいなと思っておりますとりあえず一番
驚いたのは日本以外の人が結構見ているとしそれに合わせて僕もちょっとこういろいろ
やっていかなければ
なと思っております世界のみんな待ってておくれ
100 fly いろんな抗議があったんですけどその中でピッカーとして水をみたい
にして受けることが出来たりして遊ばせるところ楽しんでる炎上するとかしっかり勉強
して大変ためにあるアメリカでの1週間だと思いますスイーツ部の中の得ない方がいる
んですけどもその方のスピーチを聞いてその中でいろいろとなればね今後の
youtube に勝つ発表があったのでそれを僕はちょっと皆さんに今回伝えようと
思いますえらい海外だと
結構みんな知ってるんですけども日本の皆様多分日度か乗ってもたっと来ないと思うの
でそこにはちょっと皆さんに今回お伝えできればいいなと思っておりますまずですね
youtube データーセンターというものが出来たらしいですマカのクリエイター
センターということ簡単にはチャンネルの成長をサポートしてくれるらしいです
こういう感じですねもうページができてますおっと責任があ席にさんがありますね
僕もいますありがとうございますごちそうさまですなぁ今度クリエイターセンター何が
あるかと言いますと youtube で行動しや成功するんだろうみたいなことが何
か一箇所にまとめてあるらしくてもうそれを見るだけで潜っていいらしいです他にもで
ユーチューバーで工場方が交換できたりつぶし z みたいなのがあるらしい見てそこ
で皆さんでお話がすることもできるらしいですが僕がやり始めたから youtube
だってなかったし
ええええ
ユーチューバーあるがどうすればいいかとか何もなかったので本当に何か手探りでやっ
てたんですけど何か困ったことがあるとすぐサポートしてくれるらしいのでは
youtube 簡単に始められるようになったなと思いますフォースそこからが2
ようですなんと
ユーチューバーが全員
色付けされるらしいねすまんぴんと来ないと思いますちょっと説明しますねだねこん
チャンネル登録者数=その返答能力みたいな感じだったんですけどまぁそれではまた
わかりやすくするためにですねユーチューバーが全員色付けされるらしいさあ皆様の
ニードなのでしょうかこちらですね出発線はグラファイトすべてのクリエイターにご
参加いただけますというわけでもうアカウントを持ってる
皆さんはグラファイトというでベルらしいです今はねできることで解放されていく
みたいでグラファイトだったら
ウェイターアカデミーという場所に学ぶことができたリクルーターツールチャンネルを
管理するそしてチャンネルの収益感サポート受けることが出来るみたいです
グラファイトの次はこちらです音 r 10人から1番にオパールになると
youtube space でイベントやワークショップに参加することが
できるみたいですこう次会とかにも参加できるみたいですよねつぎ1万人から10万人
のクリエイターの皆様ブロンズここまでくるとすごいですねアンバサダーとか
youtube space でなんかできたりするんだね交通さんだ
ますそして10万人以上も苦じゃないですか10万人以上はシルバー以上という色付け
になります実はですね youtube のチームからこのなんか担当してくれている
パートナー的なマネージャー的な方が実はうぐれていますいつもお世話になっており
ますという感じでですねチャンネル登録者数というものはただの数字ではなくてさんの
数字によってできることがどんどん増えていっててそれが
わかりやすくなったというわけでございますで今回の発表ですごい youtube が
変わったかと思ったことが一個あったんですけども
もう全員が出た youtube のサポートスタッフから1日以内で
メールが帰ってくるらしいです
本当かなぁボードスタッフが出てなんかこうメールでわからないことを問い合わせると
1営業日以内に必ずこうなんか受け取れるようにするらしいですがすごいこれで分から
ないことあったらすぐも youtube さんに聞けますからみんなビューお話です
1週間すごいいろんなことがありました映像覆面 youtube のことも勉強でき
たし英語でしゃべる機会があって何かもっと勉強したくなっちゃいましたして始めたら
アメリカ
今まで見たこと
なかったものがいろいろあってまたアメリカ行きたいなって思ってしまいました人末
言えばどんどん高みんなが使いやすいように変化していっているのでもねなんか向かす
と比べてね
ユーチューバーみたいな動画を出すようなことがすごいしやすい環境になったのかなと
思います中でこう日本だとで自撮りしてで喋ってるとちょっとおかしな人だと思われる
んですけど
日どこの会社だと結構みんなか
雨だと話せる人が多くてまあやっぱアメリカっていう2バーっていうのがすごい浸透
するなって思いましたという感じですはじめのアメリカリポートまあいろいろ勉強に
なったんですけどもまぁそれを生かしつっつーと言いつつの何適当に楽しくヘラヘラと
今後もやっていこうと思います以上アメリカからのレポートでした
じゃあな
超まじめ
持って
いいえいます
打っていた
あるいは殺そうとしませんですっ深い